Michael Cohen's public testimony could
potentially create more legal jeopardy
for a president Trump Paula Reid is at
the White House with what's next Paula
good morning we saw Michael Cohen put
President Trump at the center of these
hush money payments including bringing
that type of criminal conspiracy into
the White House and for the first time
implicated the president's oldest son
Don jr. and his chief financial officer
Alan weiselberger in that scheme what is
the potential legal fallout of that well
this could expose the president to far
more legal jeopardy than he's currently
exposed to in the Russia probe Cohen
alleges that the president continued to
engage in a conspiracy to cover-up
campaign finance violations while he was
in the White House this is currently
under investigation by federal
prosecutors in Manhattan and we learned
during the hearing that that
investigation is broadening in fact
Cohen was asked about the last time he
spoke with a president or his team he
said it was shortly after his home in
his hotel were raided by the FBI but he
couldn't reveal details of the
conversation because it was currently
under investigation and he also
confirmed that there are other
previously undisclosed matters under
criminal investigation in Manhattan
which means Paula there are
investigators actually going to see if
there's evidence to back up the things
that Michael Cohen claims let me ask you
a question about what he said about Jay
Sekulow the president's lawyer one of
the president's lawyers
he said he changed Michael Cohen's
testimony in front of Congress about
this trumped our deal in Russia Congress
has been very anxious to go after people
who don't tell them the truth what what
situation does that setup if in fact
there is something that the White House
did to change his testimony well Jay
Sekulow denied those claims one of the
things members of both parties were
interested in is why did Cohen lie and
whether or not he was directed by the
President to lie Cohen's testimony is
that the President did not directly tell
him to lie but that he believed it was
implied that he was supposed to make it
clear that there was nothing going on
with business deals in Moscow but he
said when he presented a copy of his
testimony to the president's legal team
he alleges that they made changes to it
that is something that they deny Paula
Michael Cohen gave examples of where he
said the president inflated and deflated
his net worth for tax purposes how
likely is Congress going to see his tax
returns well they're certainly gonna try
I think it's highly likely that they're
going to make an effort he gave them a
roadmap for how to pursue those tax
returns which so far have been elusive
all right Paula thank you